okay can I thank everybody that for
their patience and and forbearance we we
have come to a decision
um we satisfy that the application has
been properly made and all procedures
followed correctly
to clarify this is a is a license for
the areas shown on the plan
so the area is shown on the plan in in
the document that's all we're licensing
today
um we're going to Grant the application
with the revised hours in the amendment
as follows
live music Sunday to Thursday 10 o'clock
while 2300 hours recorded oh sorry
Sunday to Thursday Friday to Saturday 10
o'clock well 23 30 hours
recorded music Sunday to Thursday 10
o'clock well 2300 hours and Friday and
Saturday 10 o'clock well 23 30 hours
alcohol on the premises Sunday to
Thursday 10 o'clock well 2300 hours
Friday to Saturday 10 o'clock well 23 30
hours
and the opening hours Sunday to Thursday
10 o'clock well 2300 hours and Friday to
Saturday 10 o'clock well 20 23 30 hours
in addition to the conditions offered in
the operating schedule we're going to
add the conditions stipulated by the
environmental health officer in the
email dated 12th of July
summarized in the briefing note which we
all have in front of us
um
amending condition 19 as follows
all external doors and windows shall be
kept closed except in the event of
emergency after 2100 hours
the reason for this decision is it is a
residential area
and we've considered that it's an
appropriate balance between the rights
of the licensee and the rights of the
residents to enjoy a peaceful existence
so that's the decision if there are any
issues we would we would urge you to
speak to the licensee as he's offered to
do in the first instance I'm sure if you
talk to him afterwards he'd be happy to
give you his contact details but if you
speak to the licensee if there is an
issue and then if if the issue does
persist contact the licensing department
who will look into it further and
ultimately we can call a review of the
license which can be amended or even
revoked in extreme circumstances
so that's the decision of the committee
can I thank everybody for coming and
making a valuable contribution to this
decision and I trust that all parties
can go away and coexist in with a nice
peaceful future
in a lovely Village so thank you very
much for your attendance
sorry just one question do we get